do you remember how we've started with
ApS there's some of that ap right we
looked at these partial songs okay we're
going to start in exactly the same way
if I mean GP growth in common ratio
right what is this sum of the first n
terms what are those terms we actually
haven't we know what the hell okay wait
wait stop the first term it's just a by
itself and then we get the ratio coming
you might say hey hey three is enough
what's my last term ambien by this one
before I write that as you'll see in a
second I am going to put the UH the
penultimate turn on as well because it
will be useful for the next step I'm
about to do okay so I'm going to write
this that's the immediately previous
term before the last one do you agree
okay and then okay because if you think
if you want to go think back to like
your binder in your world right all
these powers they're going up nor you
from left to right yeah which means
going from right to left the powers
going down right so if n would say 10
then 10 months from benign and then this
would be eight seven six five four three
okay because how many yeah good question
how many terms are there there are n
turns right now remembering that this is
a R to the 0 okay if I entered at a R to
the N okay then from here up to a are to
the end this is this one is this is a 1
right so if I left off a how many terms
are there including my rent a out of the
n there are n terms but I actually do
have an a so this is n plus 1 terms so
this is the this is the Sun the partial
sum up to n plus 1 which is not actually
won awards okay okay so that's why I
don't end for now
now I wouldn't know what this partial
sum is what we were doing a Peas we
learnt Gauss's trick Gauss's trick which
is all about addition
it was pairing things up and adding them
now Perry things up and adding them
makes complete sense if you're trying to
do an AP because well why why does it
make your food sense hmm an AP is formed
by addition right like let's speak out
so if they're like this because you guys
know what this is to me on the terms in
the AP are a and then a plus D and then
a plus a 2 D and so on right so an AP is
formed by addition so it shouldn't
surprise us that addition is the key to
unlocking a page right this is a GP how
is it GP constructive it's not by
addition it's by multiplication so we
ought to expect that multiplication is
part of the key to unlocking this thing
that's fun right now
Gauss's trick what actually perform will
not work here right if you add the
partial sum to end to itself and try and
do some pairing in that kind of thing
nothing meaningful comes out but if I
multiply so you just told me right
if I multiply by the right thing this
thing just collapse okay the question is
now so far everything else is being
multiplied by our okay so no let's just
try it and see where it leads okay if I
take the nth partial sum and multiply
everything by our okay
this is what I write okay so the first
term is a and so when a [ __ ] I
will become yeah
the next term was a art it will become a
square okay now I'm going to include
this pin on Saturn again right when I
multiply by our what happens this index
it goes up by one yeah all right just
like all the other ones did so it'll be
a to the N minus 1 and now because that
last term is out of the moment and it's
also not aware are now I do end on a ah
in but but only because of
that's why okay now you have a look you
look at these two lines right actually
there is some pairing that will help me
here right it's a pairing of a different
kind
what pairing might be helpful here now I
could factor eyes but factorizing this
would simply get me back to here right
and so you're kind of like oh I multiply
and then factorized okay that's not very
hopeful right you mean this one is okay
so you're going to pair up a whole bunch
of turns right and get that is that what
you're saying yeah okay now I'd like you
to see where that does I'm lucky to see
where it leads
I don't think it's gonna lead nowhere
but I don't think it will lead you to
this remember that's what we're trying
to get now remember I said there's a
pairing that's happening here it's just
not as obvious and admittedly I did not
write it in the most obvious way okay
let me try and make the parry a little
more obvious if I ask you to solve some
equations simultaneously because in a
way that's what I'm asking you to do I'm
asking you to solve for this that's my
unknown if I showed you an acquaintance
inherent equations like this
this and how about that okay now if you
saw that pair of equations
just get your sublet aeneas equations
hat on right because that's what we have
here what would be the first thing it
jumps out at you to do with this pair of
equations I would subtract them because
I'm going to what's this method called
elimination this is elimination right
I'm going to eliminate now okay now you
are stay with me
what am I going to subtract and more
importantly what will I eliminate okay
what's going to disappear is any terms
that are identical you agree with that
and that's why elimination happens how
many terms do you see that are identical
here it's a it's a whole bunch of them
right look here we go this guy and this
guy they're identical so they're gonna
go right when I subtract this guy and
this guy they're gonna disappear because
they're identical right you following
okay
now by the way doesn't matter which one
I subtract from which if I if I call
this because you wanted equation and see
right so it doesn't matter in this case
it does not matter because I have a
finite number of terms remember I'll
show you how bad the infinity breaks
this in a second okay for now though I'm
just gonna take the second one and
subtract the first one from it okay so
this is my next one
yeah okay now remember all of these
terms are disappearing any terms that
are in common between them will
disappear I've already got the first
term in column there what is that final
tournament in common between them
good it's the biggest time in the first
one and beyond water I should say
because the last time the first one and
it's the second last one so we'll see
we'll see what happens if you go the
other way around you'll see it won't end
up being too much of fun by the way as
I'll demonstrate therefore since all of
these guys I paired up vanish away I get
left with a and take away this lone
survivor up here okay that's all that's
left behind and now that's the guts of
the proof I don't have to do much more
to this do i what would you do on the
left-hand side what am i trying to get
again I'm trying to make s in the
subject right so I'm going to factorize
him out leaving back inside C which
gives me and now my last line right it's
it's slightly beautiful actually in how
simple it is the nth partial sum I
actually think this is much more
attractive okay now let's just suppose
let's let's reach play make-believe
right um if I had gone the other way and
done first line take away second right
instead of our -1 inhuman a factorized
oh my amorous moment i minus 1 but the
same time this guy will switch around as
well right I will get 1 minus on yet and
in fact that's an important form we're
going to write it down because it's so
useful if you switch everything around
and by the way you didn't need to peel
that far to go back off to you to see
what happened with you order all you
need to do is multiply the numerator and
denominator both by minus 1 that let us
switch the order around to see that ok
but if these are useful in their own
circumstances
right most notably if I was a big number
if I was a big number like two or three
or four or five or hundred right then if
you put it in here you get a positive
whereas if you put it in here you'll get
a negative right because a big number
what number would I want that makes the
denoted positive area either either a
very negative number or or a fraction
like if I if I had a half or a quarter
or a third in there I'd still get a
positive number yeah we tend to what
positives when there's not enough right
so depending on your value of R you'll
choose one of these just like depending
on what information like God you choose
one or the other form of fionna 18
someone